like many things that help our
relationships couples therapy
has a habit of sounding appallingly
unromantic involving patients grueling
work and a host of embarrassing
conversations about matters it would be
much easier never to have to think about
let alone discuss with a partner and a
trained stranger our culture teaches us
to trust and follow our feelings but
couples therapy knows that this is
normally a disaster for our feelings are
for the most part errant and encoded
with primitive responses from a troubled
past
so instead couples therapy encourages a
far wiser response standing well back
from our first impulses neutralizing
them through understanding and where
possible we routing them unless
self-punishing
and more trusting directions living
alongside another person is obviously
one of the hardest things we ever
attempt we should expect to get it wrong
unaided and feel unashamed about the
need for in-depth training there are a
number of vital things we might learn in
couples therapy for a start in a quiet
room we finally have the chance to
define what we feel the problems in the
relationship really are without things
immediately degenerating into shouting
sulking or cynical avoidance we're
normally far to cross with or upset by
our partner to be able to share with
them in a way they'd understand what
we're actually so angry and upset about
it helps to be in front of a stranger
we're both a little intimidated by and
have to behave ourselves with it's
highly unusual to be able to put things
so starkly but also so reasonably for
example the fact that you never touch me
and behave so limply and
unenthusiastically when I touch you is
slowly killing me and though I love you
I don't know how much longer I can take
it how much better this sort of thing
than a decade of low-level sniping and
repressed
fury secondly therapists are skilled
teasing out from us why what bothers us
bothers us normally left to our own
devices we don't unearth the emotional
meaning behind our positions we squabble
about where to go on the weekend rather
than explaining what exactly going out
or staying in represents for us
internally and as a result the other
finds us merely stubborn and mean and
all that's interesting and poignant in
our position is lost thirdly therapists
break up unseen repeated patterns of
upset and retaliation a classic
therapeutic game is to ask both parties
to fill in the blanks when you I feel
odd and I respond by dot so when you
disregard the children I feel rejected
and then respond by trying to control
who you see in the evenings or when you
don't touch me in bed I feel invisible
and respond by being ungrateful about
your money with a therapist acting as an
honest broker new contracts can be drawn
up along the lines of if you do X I will
do Y once we get a little bit of what we
really want but usually haven't properly
asked for the other's needs
feel a lot less onerous and hateful
sometimes the advice at couples
counseling is almost beautifully
pedantic name three things you resent
about your partner and next three things
you deeply appreciate also keep the
criticism specific so not your cold and
ungrateful but if you can call me when
you're running late then families can be
kept intact with little more than this
through couples therapy we are
challenged to abandon some of our
grimmer ideas about how people can be
and what will happen to us in love if I
am vulnerable I'm not necessarily going
to be hurt I might try to explain and
the other might listen we are given the
security to throw
some of the scripts we grew up with
about the futility of ever trying to be
understood we can start to be moved by
another's pain what does it feel like a
good therapist will ask to hear your
partner explain how it is for them when
you we can start to take care of each
other
a remarkable idea comes to the fore that
this other person isn't really our enemy
that they like us have some very bad
ways of getting across
what are at heart some very
understandable and touching needs
couples therapy is a classroom where we
can learn how to love we're normally so
embarrassed about not having the first
clue how to do so we leave things until
we're too angry or despairing to do
anything but hate the most hopeful and
therefore romantic thing we can ever do
in love is sometimes to declare that we
haven't yet learned how to love but with
a little help are very keen to learn one
day the School of Life offers
professional couples counseling with
qualified psychotherapists that can
benefit people at all stages of their
relationships if you would like to learn
more click the link on your screen now